but we have any of your office people
have they come yes Angela came the first
first week Oscar came Andy Buckley who
played David Wallace Creed Bratton who
plays creed bratton and unless they have
a bigger please Stanley Carell did a
video for me I mean okay he's the nice
say he's the great there's something
very love course he did because when
they pulled his hair out I don't know
like your pants she loved me I ran into
Mona asked his wife I was like you give
me the truth and she did it was nice I
do hear that there might be a reboot of
the office is that real because can I
sign a petition or something I am not
the one getting in the way if that is
happening I I wouldn't love to I mean
seriously it was the best it wasn't yeah
ever yeah my gosh yes people are living
and breathing the office right now
like literally they they will come up to
you and say I I fall asleep to you every
night now a few years ago that might
creep me out but I like it that I watch
it's like a white noise I leave it on
all day all day all day I'm like wait a
minute that means you're not paying
attention but it's like in there yeah in
there in abandoning its I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this